I am the champion and you're gonna hear
me never really heard a guy sing that
song but it was really good thank you by
the way when you shower in here we've
gone huh you just look at my boobs
I was not my intention I didn't you like
them right now now I did because we were
talking about testing Oh failed oh my
god okay you just like this one again
[Music]
you never forget the one who steals your
heart or the one oh who kicks your ass
[Music]
some baby [ __ ] is happening on our Beach
and my balls say we need to go over
there and check it out did that idea
Mitch we're lifeguards my ball day is
just thinking he's right
well my balls are saying walk that noise
let's go handle business
your balls are bullies they watch work
because we follow rules this god train
wreck
Neb rody and not a single tussle given
what a bet for is in the whole world
would like if a human [ __ ] jetty
which is impossible to be so cool
[Music]
there's your cop
don't jack off on my sheep just remember
I'm always watching Leon
[Music]
I hear the captain
All Things Considered being a lot worse
fine that's good luck pick it up my dog
we need search for more evidence checks
painfully Vermont you want me to check
his taint lifts his [ __ ] scrotum and
check his taint here at the taint man it
ain't even look good closer
oh ho like yogurt oh there's the hole
that's just his bottle smile most of
that do not post that it's a head full
of balls that he turns into nails into
the goddamn X game because we were in
lifeguard pursuit oh okay love it except
for there's no [ __ ] such thing as
lifeguard pursue
[Music]
you